vous voyez des éoliennes là se sont
couchés cd viennent vont elles tombent
parfaitement où il démenti les baisses
selon les besoins des petits
perpignanais la découverte des éoliennes
du centre d'essai vernier de lastours
ses élèves de l'école lamartine dans le
cadre des journées de l'enfance de la
ville de perpignan
on travaillait tout d'abord sur les
comptes du moulin à vent mais de la
littérature ils sont passés à la science
le vent en tant que source d'énergie
l école primaire actuellement nous avons
un souci c'est d'éduquer nos enfants à
l'écocitoyenneté
donc j'ai pensé qu'on pouvait travailler
l'énergie et puis en passer à l'économie
d'énergie
je crois qu'au jour d'aujourd'hui il
faut penser énergies renouvelables et
les enfants saisissent très vite des
aspects positifs de cette énergie
naturelle c'est économique c'est rapide
là l'éolienne faveur des énergies de
chauffage pas au total une vingtaine
d'écoles et de centres aérés de
perpignan on travaille depuis janvier
sur les thèmes de la ville et de l'art
les manifestations grand public de ces
journées de l'enfance à perpignan sont
programmés du 6 au 10 juin prochain
je suis né l'argent